let's say i have a magnetic field
popping out of this video so these
little brown circles show us the the
tips of the vectors popping out of this
of our screen
and then in that magnetic field i have
this wire this
off-white colored wire and sitting on
that off-white colored wire i have a
charge of charge q and let me write down
the other stuff so this is the magnetic
field
b
coming out
and let's take let's say i were to take
this whole wire let's say that the wire
overlaps with the magnetic field
a distance of l so let's say the
magnetic field stops here
and stops here
and let's say that this distance right
here
that distance is l
i drew it a little bit weird but you get
the idea from here to here is l i have
this charge sitting on this some type of
conductor that we can consider a wire
and the magnetic field is pushing out of
the page so
in this current formation let's say you
know i don't have any voltage across
this y or anything what's going to
happen well if i just have a stationary
charge sitting in a magnetic field
nothing really is going to happen right
because we know that the force due to a
magnetic field
the force due to a magnetic field
is equal to
the charge
times the cross product of the velocity
of the charge
and the magnetic field
if this wire is a stationary and there's
no voltage across x x r the velocity of
this charge is going to be zero so the
velocity is zero we know that you know
the magnitude of a cross product
is the same thing as
so q is you know that's just a scalar
quantity so that's just q
times the magnitude of the velocity
times the magnitude
of b times sine theta
and in these situations where uh what
you know ever anything that's going on
in this plane is going to be
perpendicular to this magnetic field so
the the angle between the magnetic field
and any velocity if there were any
within this plane would be 90 degrees so
you wouldn't have to worry about the
sine theta too much but we see if the
velocity is zero or the speed is zero
the magnitude of the velocity is zero
that this there's not going to be any
net force due to the magnetic field on
this charge and nothing interesting
isn't going to happen
but let's do a little experiment
what happens if i were to move this wire
if i were to shift it to the left with
the velocity v
so i take this wire and i shift it to
the left whoops yeah
with the velocity v right so the whole
wire shifting to the left
well the whole wire shifting to the left
this charge is sitting on that wire
right
so that charge is also going to move to
the left with the velocity v
and now things get interesting
the charge is moving to the left with
the velocity v so now we can apply the
first magnetism formula that we learned
we could we can apply this formula so
what's going to happen to this charge
well the force of the charge is going to
be the charge times the magnitude of the
velocity across this the magnetic field
vector but what's what's so we know that
there's going to be some net force this
is non-zero now
and this is non-zero we're assuming and
we're assuming the charge is non-zero so
what direction is the force going to be
in so let's do our right hand rule on
the cross product v cross b will give us
the direction so point your index finger
in the direction of the velocity
and i have to look at my own hand to
make sure i'm doing it right
so you point your index finger in the
direction of the velocity
point your middle finger in the
direction of the magnetic field the
magnetic field is popping out of the
page so your middle finger is actually
going to be popping out of the page
your next two fingers are just going to
do something like that so
you're kind of approximating like you're
shooting a gun and then what's your
thumb going to do your thumb is going to
point straight up
so this is your this is the palm of
that's your thumb
this is this could be your nail
fingernail fingernail your thumb
fingernail of your middle finger right
this is the direction of the velocity
suitable color the velocity is that way
the magnetic field is popping out
of the page
so the force create on the particle on
this charged particle or on this uh well
on this charge due to the magnetic field
is going to go in the direction of your
thumb
so the direction of the force is in this
direction
so the
force so what's going to happen
there's going to be a net force in this
direction on the charge
and the charge is going to move upwards
right
so what what i mean when you start
having a moving you could imagine also
that you had a multiple charges right if
you had multiple charges here and you're
moving the whole wire all of those
charges are going to be moving upwards
and what is
another way to call a bunch of moving
charges along a conductor well it's a
current depending on how much charge is
moving per second so at least in a very
in very qualitative terms you see that
when you move a wire through a magnetic
field or when you move a magnetic field
past a wire right because they're kind
of the same thing it's all about the
relative motion but if you move a wire
through a magnetic field is actually
going to induce a current
in the wire and we can actually
it's going to induce the current in the
wire and actually this is how
electric generators are generated and
i'll do a whole series of videos on on
how you you know if you have a using
coal or steam or hydro hydro power how
that turns
essentially that turns these generators
around and it induces current and that's
how we get electricity from all of these
you know various energy sources that
essentially just make turbines turn
but anyway let's go back to what we were
doing so let me ask you a question if
this if this particle
and this all has a point if this
particle starts at like kind of the
beginning let's say the particle is
right here so it starts right where the
magnetic field starts affecting the wire
and how much work is going to be done on
the particle by the magnetic field
well what's work work is equal to
work is equal to force
times distance where the force has to be
in the same direction as the distance
right force times distance i won't mess
with the vectors right now but they have
to be the same direction so how much
work is going to be done on this
particle
so the work is going to be the net force
exerted on the particle times the
distance
well this distance is l right we say
once the particle gets here there's no
magnetic field up here so
the magnetic field will stop acting on
it so the total work done
work which is equal to force times
distance is equal to so the net force is
this up here
q
and i'll leave some space v
cross b
times the distance and the distance
right here is just a scalar quantity so
we could put it out front right q
times
l
times v cross b right this is q v cross
b is the force times the distance that's
just the work done
now how much work is being done per
charge right this this is how much work
is being done on this charge but let's
say you know there might have been
multiple charges we just want to know
how much work is done per charge so work
per charge we could divide both sides by
charge
so work
per charge is equal to this per charge
so it is equal to
the distance
times
the velocity that you're pulling the
wire to the left with
cross
the magnetic field
this is where it gets interesting
so what is work per charge the units of
work are energy right joules and charge
that's in coulombs so what is the what
what are joules
joules per coulomb
joules per coulomb
this is equal to volts
volts are joules per coulomb so this
this
particle or these charges are going to
start moving in this direction as if
there is a voltage difference as if
there is a potential difference between
this point and this point as if this
there's you know this is a positive
voltage terminal and this is a minus
voltage terminal so there's actually
going to be a voltage or a perceived
voltage difference between this point at
this point that will start making the
current flow let's say you didn't even
know that there was a magnetic field
here you would just see this current
flowing like oh well there has to be a
voltage difference there right but when
we're dealing with this because you know
when we talk about voltages that was
like a potential difference that
something that
that that a particle or charge has a
higher potential energy and that's why
it's moving but it's hard to at least
for these purposes to say well you have
a higher potential energy here it's hard
to it's really been created by the the
magnetic field so in this context people
have said that instead of saying that
this is creating a voltage difference
between this point and this point that
the magnetic field on the moving wire is
causing that people say that it's
creating an electromotive force or an
emf but emf the units are still joules
per coulomb or volts and it really is in
every way when you're analyzing the
circuit still the same thing as a
potential difference or as a voltage
difference but since it seems a little
bit more proactive it seems like this
magnetic
field is actually
impacting a force on this wire that is
causing the current to move we call it
emf right so we can say that the emf the
electromotive force
or the voltage across from here to here
but that
they're really the same thing is equal
to
the distance of the wire that's in the
magnetic field
times the velocity that you're pulling
the wire in across the magnetic field
so let's say i don't know let's just
throw out a bunch of numbers let's say
that the magnetic field is i'll make it
easy two teslas
my velocity to the left is
3
meters per second
and let's just for fun let's give this a
little bit of a resistance
just so we can figure out something so
let's say this resistance is i don't
know let's say it is
it is 6 ohms
there's a 6 ohm resistor here so the
resistance of the wire from here to here
is 6 ohms all wires have some resistance
so first of all what's the emf
oh and let's say that this total
distance right here let's say that total
distance is 12. 12
meters so the emf for induced on the or
the electromotive force put on to the
wire by the magnetic field is going to
equal the distance of the wire in the
magnetic field 12 meters
times
well when we're just taking the cross
product we know that the velocity is
perpendicular to the
magnetic field so we don't have to worry
about sine theta because theta is
already 90 degrees so we just have to
worry about the magnitudes so it's going
to be 12 meters times the velocity which
is 3 meters per second
times the magnetic field or the
magnitude of the magnetic field that's
two teslas
and so the emf is 12 times 3 times 212
times 6 which is 72
you could say 20
72 volts or 72 joules per coulomb
and now you have that potential
difference or that emf across a 6 ohm
resistor
right so that's you just go back to
voltage is equal to ir or you could
write emf
is equal to ir
so emf divided by resistance
so if we take this emf and we divide it
by the resistance
divided by 6 ohms
we get the current right emf divided by
resistance is equal to
current so you divide 72
volts or 72 joules per coulomb divided
by 6 ohms and then you get a current
going along the this wire right here due
to the emf due to the magnetic field i
know it's very messy at this point of 12
amperes
anyway i'm all out of time i'll see in
the next video